صافرات الانذار هذه
دوت قبل نحو يعني ما يقرب من ال 40 دقيقه
من الان لا ادري اذا كانت هناك اي اصداء
لها وماذا يمكن ان يكون وقعها وما مداها
واين وصلت كل هذه الاسئله لعلك تحاول ان
ان تجيب
عليها عثمان واضح بان هنالك اثر معنوي
كبير على ضرب مدينه تلي ابيب بالصواريخ
بعد هذه الايام الطويله من هذه حرب على
اعتبار ان تل ابيب تمثل رمزا وقلبا نابضا
لاسرائيل على الصعيد الاقتصادي وهو المكان
يعني تل ابيب وتل ابيب الكبرى كل المدن
المحيطه فيها هي المكان الذي يعيش فيه
العدد الاكبر من الاسرائيليين وكانت
الجبهه الداخليه قد اعادت الاسرائيليين في
هذه المناطق لممارسه حياتهم الاعتياديه
والطبيعيه ضمن اجراءات الطوارئ ال
المعتاده في حدها الادنى بطبيعه الحال لكن
واضح بان مثل هذه الضربه بعد 74 يوما من
عمر هذه الحرب يعني تعيدنا وكاننا في
اليوم الاول حقيقه لهذه الحرب لان ان تضرب
تل ابيب هذا ليس امرا سهلا وليس امرا
عبثيا وواضح بانه يشير الى قدرات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي ما زالت تملك هذه القدره
على تحديد المكان والزمان والمدي التي
تطلق فيها هذه الصواريخ وهي تثير كثير من
التحفظات وكثير من التساؤلات ايضا في
اوساط السياسيين والعسكريين في اسرائيل لا
سما اولئك الذين يجلسون في الاستديوهات
التحليليه ويراقبون ويحللون من منطلق
المراقب من منطلق المشاهد الذي لا يملك
القدره على اتخاذ القرار السياسي ولا
القرار العسكري لكن ربما موقفهم ربما يكون
اكثر ايجابيه وموضوعيه في التعاطي مع هذه
ال المساله وهم يتساءلون بكثير من من
الحرقه حقيقه عندما تسمعهم عبر
التلفزيونات الاسرائيليه ويقولون يعني ما
الذي ي يحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي يصب جام
غضبه وحمامه و قنابله وصواريخه الذكيه
ولديه كل
التكنولوجيا المتطوره على وجه هذه ال
البسيطه ولكنه لا يستطيع ان يخمد نيران
هذه الصواريخ التي تطلق باتجاه المدن
الاسرائ
ال الكبرى وبالتالي يتساءلون ايضا عن
الجدوى من هذه العمليه العسكريه التي اولا
لم تحقق اي انتصار عسكري يمكن الاشاره
اليه بالبنان بان هذا انجاز عسكري يحسب
للجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه العمليه المستمره
ل
74 يوما وفي المقابل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي تقدر على اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
وتوجيهها الى قلب اسرائيل الى عمق اسرائيل
الى مدينه تلي ابيب وادون ان تكون لل يكون
للجانب الاسرائيلي القدره على اخمادها رغم
العمليه العسكريه البريه والتوغل البريه
والعمق الذي وصلت اليه القوات الاسرائيليه
القصف المدفعي الشديد الذي يكاد لا يتوقف
على مدار الساعه وعلى مدار الدقيقه في
احيان كثيره عثمان ولا الغارات الجويه
التي ايه دمرت مساحات شاسعه من من قطاع
غزه وكذلك البحريه الاسرائيليه التي تدخل
على خط هذه المواجهه من ناحيه اخرى